>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
ON "TOP MODEL" LAST WEEK...
>> THE WINNER--
ALEXANDRIA, IT'S YOURS.
>> I REALLY THINK THAT NIGEL
MADE THE WRONG DECISION.
YOU PICKED
THE UGLIEST (bleep) PERSON HERE.
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> YOU ACTUALLY KINDA
GIVE ME CRAZY QUITE NATURALLY.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE JUST LOOKING
AND GOING, "I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO GO FOR."
>> BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
SO MUCH STUFF.
>> THERE WAS THIS SORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY PERFORMANCE
BETWEEN YOU AND BRITTANI.
>> YOU REALLY CHOSE
THE WRONG SPOKESPERSON
BECAUSE WE SEE
THE TRUE ALEXANDRIA.
>> YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
THE CLIENT AND YOU HAVE TO
RESPECT YOURSELF.
>> I'M HAVING A PANIC ATTACK.
I CAN'T REALLY... (gasps) TALK.
>> I WAS OUTVOTED.
BRITTANI.
MIKAELA WAS ELIMINATED.
SIX GIRLS ARE LEFT,
ALL VYING FOR A CHANCE
TO BE IN ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE HAD PANEL,
AND THAT WAS PRETTY MUCH
THE WORST DAY OF MY LIFE.
>> I HAVE A SERIOUS ISSUE
WITH HOW THESE JUDGES VOTED,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO
TO PROVE THAT YOU DESERVE
TO BE HERE.
IT IS UP TO YOU
TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> (crying) AND SO NOW
SHE JUST SEES ME
AS THIS HORRIBLE PERSON.
(sniffles) AND I CAN'T GO HOME
BECAUSE I KNOW I...
WHETHER TYRA THINKS
I DESERVE TO BE HERE,
I KNOW I DESERVE TO BE HERE.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING, LIKE,
CAN WE KIND OF, LIKE, JUST
CLEAR THE PLATE AND START OVER?
'CAUSE I APPROACHED THIS
ALL WRONG BY BITING MY TONGUE.
LIKE, THAT'S JUST HOW I AM,
TRYING TO BE NONCONFRONTATIONAL.
>> RIGHT.
>> BECAUSE THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON I EXPLODED,
BECAUSE I KEPT IT ON THE INSIDE.
>> I KNOW AND...
>> AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR EXPLODING.
>> THANK YOU FOR APOLOGIZING.
>> ALEXANDRIA AND I--
WE KINDA HASHED IT OUT,
AND I APOLOGIZED
FOR MAKING THE DECISIONS I DID
AND HOW I ACTED.
>> ABOUT WHAT SHE DID--
ALMOST UNFORGIVABLE.
YOU KNOW, CAN I TRUST THEM?
I'M NOT DUMB...
>> LET'S HUG THIS OUT.
>> BUT I AM A FORGIVER.
>> WE'RE GONNA BE COOL.
>> WE'RE CLEAR.
>> THE ATTITUDE NOW
REGARDING ALEXANDRIA
HAS KIND OF FLIPPED.
>> EVERYONE'S PUT ON THIS FAÇADE
AND BEEN OKAY WITH ME,
WHEN YOU SHOULD'VE
JUST BEEN HONEST.
>> I WOULD
NEVERGO UP TO--
TO SOMEONE AND S-SAY
"I WANT YOU TO GO HOME."
>> YOU SHOULD'VE BEEN
JUST REAL WITH ME, GIRL.
>> YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY'S
BREATHING BETTER NOW
BECAUSE WE LET IT ALL OUT
IN THE OPEN
AND EVERYBODY FEELS BETTER.
>> I HAVE NO PROBLEMS
WITH YOU GUYS.
>> ALEXANDRIA FRUSTRATES
THE HELL OUT OF ME.
SHE PUTS ON THIS ACT.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, SO FAKE,
AND EVERYBODY BUYS IT,
WHICH I THINK IS
JUST RIDICULOUS.
LIKE, HOW DUMB ARE YOU PEOPLE?
UGH.
>> AFTER PANEL, WE ARRIVE
AT THIS DARK ART GALLERY...
>> HI, LADIES.
>> AND TYRA'S THERE.
AND WE SEE ALL OF OUR PICTURES
DISPLAYED LIKE
A-A PIECE OF ART.
>> WELCOME TO
MY HALL OF PORTFOLIOS.
>> (squeals)
>> SO WE HAVE PORTFOLIOS
TO SEE CLIENTS TO GET BOOKED.
THE WORLD IS NOT JUST ABOUT
TAKING PRETTY PICTURES
AND STUFF.
YEAH, THAT'S KIND OF THE--
WHAT YOU DO,
BUT THERE'S A REASON
WHY WE TAKE PICTURES.
IT'S TO BOOK JOBS.
I'M GONNA TAKE YOU THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF HOW
YOU PUT TOGETHER A PORTFOLIO.
THE FIRST PICTURE
THAT YOU WANT TO SEE IS
A CLOSE-UP FACE SHOT
OR SOMETHING THAT HAS
SOME POWER.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH KASIA.
WE DID THIS
BECAUSE IT IS YOUR FACE,
IT IS LOVELY, IT PULLS YOU IN,
AND IT IS PURE YOU.
SO YOU GRAB THEM WITH YOUR FACE
AND THEN YOU END WITH SOMETHING
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL BORE
INTO THEIR HEADS
OR CREATE A CONVERSATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, KASIA,
YOU ONLY HAVE FOUR.
BUT YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED TO HAVE A LOT
TO WOW A CLIENT.
I BOOKED 25 FASHION SHOWS
IN PARIS
OFF OF ONE, TWO, THREE PHOTOS.
SO YOU HAVE FOUR.
SO YOU HAVE A LEG UP.
>> I REALLY LEARNED THAT
PUTTING TOGETHER A PORTFOLIO
IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT HAS TO FLOW,
AND IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
LESS PICTURES THAT ARE GREAT
THAN A BUNCH OF CRAPPY PICTURES.
>> WE START HERE WITH
THIS LOVELY 1980s CAROL ALT
KIND OF FEELING THERE,
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA END WITH
"YEAH, I LIKE MY MAKEUP,
AND I LOST MY MIND. WHAT?"
>> ALL OF YOUR PICTURES,
OF COURSE, NEED TO BE STRONG,
BUT THEN YOU REALLY HAVE TO HAVE
THAT FIERCE PICTURE AT THE END
SO THAT THOSE CLIENTS
WILL NOT FORGET YOU.
>> MOLLY, I THINK YOU LOOK LIKE
A BEAUTIFUL
GRECIAN GODDESS/ATHLETE,
BUT HIGH FASHION.
AND THEN YOU'RE STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANG WITH YOUR GOLDEN SISTERS
HERE.
AND I SAY WE END HERE.
THIS IS SO STRONG,
AND THEY'LL GO, "OH, SO NICE."
OR MAYBE IN L.A.,
"OH, MY GOD. THAT'S SO COOL."
THAT'S WHAT THEY'LL DO.
BRITTANI.
ONE THING THE FASHION INDUSTRY
LOVES ARE THINGS THAT ARE
KIND OF WEIRD,
THINGS THAT ARE INTERESTING,
AND THAT'S THIS LONGNECK.
THAT'S GONNA CATCH THE EYE
OF A CLIENT, LIKE,
"DANG! WHAT IS GOING ON THERE?"
AND THEN WE END WITH
"LOOK AT MY CONTROL."
>> I STILL FEEL
KIND OF AWKWARD WITH TYRA
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED AT PANEL,
SO I'M JUST GONNA
KEEP MY MOUTH SHUT.
>> EVERYBODY GRAB
THEIR PORTFOLIOS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW SOMETHING.
I NEED YOU TO UNDERSTAND.
I NEED YOU TO "C"
WHERE YOU'LL BE GOING OVERSEAS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> AND IN YOUR PORTFOLIOS ARE
THE REST OF THE LETTERS
OF THE INTERNATIONAL LOCATION
THAT YOU GUYS ARE GOING.
>> I'M THINKING,
CUBA, CHINA, CHILE.
>> CANADA?
>> OPEN UP YOUR BOOKS NOW
AND YOU FIGURE OUT
WHERE YOU WILL BE GOING.
>> I'M THINKING, OH, MY LORD.
LET'S JUST GET THESE LETTERS
ON THE GROUND
AND PUT 'EM TOGETHER.
I WANNA KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING.
>> NO, "M," "O"...
>> MOROCCO!
>> IT'S GOTTA BE.
>> IT'S MOROCCO. IT'S MOROCCO.
>> GIMME FIVE. GIMME FIVE.
GIMME FIVE.
>> I AM SO EXCITED.
I REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY CAN'T WAIT
TO GO TO MOROCCO.
>> I HAVE DONE PHOTO SHOOTS
ALL OVER THE ENTIRE WORLD.
THIS PLACE IS
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING--
THE PEOPLE, THE MARKETS,
THE SPICES.
YOU GUYS ARE
SOME OF THE LUCKIEST
"TOP MODEL" GIRLS EVER.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> SO TOMORROW,
YOU HAVE GO-SEES.
GO-SEES TOMORROW
WILL WEIGH HEAVILY
ON WHO GOES HOME
AND WHO GOES TO MOROCCO.
BOOK THE JOBS,
GET TO MOROCCO.
YOU DON'T, YOU GO HOME.
I ONLY GOT FIVE MORE SEATS
ON THE PLANE.
>> I THOUGHT ALL SIX OF US
WERE GONNA GO,
BUT IT TURNS OUT
THAT ONE OF US IS NOT.
(chuckles)
>> I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
>> THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (screaming)
>> WE GOT GO-SEES TOMORROW!
>> LOOK AT YOUR PHOTO!
>> OH, MY GOD.
OKAY, BEAUTIFUL PICTURE, JACLYN.
>> AAH!
>> I THINK I'M DOING PRETTY GOOD
IN THE COMPETITION.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE EVERY WEEK
I KEEP MOVING UP,
AND I FEEL LIKE NOT ONLY
HAVE I GROWN AS A MODEL,
BUT I'VE GROWN AS A WOMAN.
AND I JUST FEEL VERY CONFIDENT.
♪♪♪♪♪
(doorbell rings)
>> HI. HOW ARE YOU?
>> HI. I'M--I'M GREAT.
I'M MOLLY.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> HI, GIRLS.
I'M KYLE HAGLER FROM IMG MODELS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, WE REPRESENT
LAST CYCLE'S WINNER,
AND SOON ONE OF YOU
WILL BE REPRESENTED
BY US AS WELL.
I AM HERE FOR GO-SEES.
YOU ALL KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
GO-SEES ARE FOR YOU
AND TO YOUR CAREER.
>> AFTER
MY WHOLE PANEL INCIDENT,
I FEEL THAT I NEED
TO PROVE MYSELF MORE
THAN ANY OTHER GIRL HERE TODAY,
AND SO IT'S
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT DAY
FOR ME.
>> YOU'LL HAVE FOUR HOURS TO GET
TO FOUR DIFFERENT CASTINGS.
YOU MUST MEET ME
AT THE FIFTH AND LAST GO-SEE,
LANA MARKS, BY 3:00 P.M.
THE THREE WINNERS
OF TODAY'S CHALLENGE
WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THE ULTIMATE GO-SEE
AT LANA MARKS' SALON.
EACH OF THESE CASTINGS
WILL REPRESENT
A DIFFERENT ARCHETYPE--
ATHLETIC, BOMBSHELL,
GIRL NEXT DOOR, AND COUTURE.
YOU WILL ALL HAVE TO PACK
ONE BAG
THAT WILL PREPARE YOU
FOR EACH OF THESE ARCHETYPES.
EACH OF YOU HAS A CAR
WAITING FOR YOU OUTSIDE,
AND DRIVER.
>> WOW.
>> YOU'LL BE GIVEN A MAP BOOK,
BUT YOUR DRIVER
CANNOT GIVE YOU DIRECTIONS.
>> I'M SO SCREWED.
THE ONLY OTHER MAP
THAT I'VE EVER READ WAS
IN WORLD GEOGRAPHY,
AND LORD HELP ME,
BECAUSE I ALWAYS GOT IN TROUBLE
FOR TALKING IN THAT CLASS.
>> IF ANY OF YOU
ARRIVES AFTER 3:00 P.M.,
YOU'RE AUTOMATICALLY
DISQUALIFIED FROM THE CHALLENGE.
>> THESE GO-SEES ARE IN L.A.
NO ONE ELSE IS FROM L.A.
(whispers) I'M FROM L.A.
(normal voice) I'M GONNA DO
ALL RIGHT.
>> I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT WAS SO NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> BYE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> GO!
>> WE RUN OUTSIDE
AND ALL OUR DRIVERS ARE THERE.
>> I'M ALEXANDRIA.
>> HI. JOHN.
>> HI.
>> HI, I'M HANNAH.
>> WE'RE GOING.
>> SO THERE ARE FOUR GO-SEES
WITHIN THE FOUR HOURS,
PLUS THE FINAL GO-SEE.
AND THE CLOSEST ONE WAS
THE BOMBSHELL, SO I'M LIKE,
WELL, I'M GOING TO THAT ONE
FIRST BECAUSE IF I GOT LOST,
I WAS GONNA BE UP (bleep) CREEK
WITHOUT A PADDLE.
>> GO STRAIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> I KNOW L.A.
LIKE THE BACK OF MY HAND,
AND OUR FIRST GO-SEE IS
RIGHT DOWN 9th STREET--
FRANKIE B.'s
AT THE NEW MART BUILDING,
AND I'M GONNA DO AWESOME.
>> THE FIRST PLACE IS
RIGHT DOWN THE STREET,
BUT I-I CAN'T FIND THE NUMBER.
(groans)
AND I'M LIKE, WHAT THE HELL?
I CAN'T FIGURE THIS OUT.
THIS IS BULL... (bleep).
>> HOW DO YOU WORK THIS THING?
>> WE HAVE FOUR HOURS
TO GET TO FOUR DIFFERENT GO-SEES
BEFORE OUR 3:00 DEADLINE
AT OUR FIFTH GO-SEE,
SO THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
TO STAY CALM.
>> I AM NOT GOOD
WITH DIRECTIONS.
I DON'T READ MAPS, SO I'M JUST--
I'M WANDERING AROUND.
HILL. HILL. HILL.
I HATE MY LIFE.
OFFICIALLY HATE IT.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> HI. I'M DANIELLA
FROM FRANKIE B.
>> I'M ALEXANDRIA.
I KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> ALEXANDRIA, NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> I'M PISSED OFF.
I'M REALLY PISSED OFF RIGHT NOW.
AND THEN I GET HERE,
AND EVERYBODY'S--I'M GONNA BE
THE VERY, VERY LAST ONE TO GO.
I KINDA WANNA LEAVE
AND JUST GO TO THE NEXT THING.
SO I'M PISSED. I'M PISSED OFF.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M GONNA DO YET.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I FINALLY GET THERE,
AND THERE'S THE GIRLS
WAITING IN FRONT OF ME.
SO I'M LIKE,
I'M JUST GONNA SKIP THIS
AND JUST HOPE TO GOD
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS GET LOST.
SO I JUST LEFT.
TOO MANY (bleep)...
TOO MANY (bleep) PEOPLE THERE
AND I WOULD BE WAITING
FOR AN HOUR, SO WE'RE GOING
TO THE NEXT PLACE.
>> I KNOW A LOT ABOUT FRANKIE B.
YOU'RE COMPLETELY, LIKE, ROCK,
COOL-INSPIRED,
AND YOU CAN TOTALLY TELL.
AND THEY'RE SWEET.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> A LITTLE BUTT-KISSING
NEVER HURT ANYBODY.
ALEXANDRIA WAS VERY SWEET,
VERY PERSONABLE,
AND I LOVE
THAT SHE KNEW THE BRAND,
SO I WOULD DEFINITELY
BOOK ALEXANDRIA.
>> GRACIAS.
>> YOU KNOW, SLOW DOWN
SO (bleep) GET IN FRONT OF YOU,
YOU (bleep).
I DO NOT LIKE TRAFFIC.
I DON'T LIKE PEDESTRIANS.
WE NEED TO GET OVER.
I REALLY WANTED TO SHOVE
THE DUDE OUT OF MY CAR AND BE
LIKE, "CAN I PLEASE DRIVE?
YOU'RE NOT AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS."
>> FRANKIE B. IS
A SEXY DENIM LINE
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF ROCK EDGE,
AND BRITTANI PROVIDES
THAT KINDA EDGINESS
WHICH I REALLY LIKE.
HANNAH HAS A GREAT BODY.
AND KASIA FIT THE JEANS WELL,
AND SHE DEFINITELY HAS
THAT BOMBSHELL LOOK
THAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
>> I THOUGHT I DID VERY WELL
IN THE FIRST GO-SEE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I KNOW
I'M THE GIRL NEXT DOOR,
BUT I'VE GOT SOME VA VA VOOM
INSIDE OF ME.
YOU HAVE A NICE DAY.
>> YOU TAKE CARE.
AFTER MEETING JACLYN,
I HAVE A BIT OF A TOOTHACHE,
'CAUSE SHE'S SO SWEET.
>> OH, LORD.
HURRY, HURRY, HURRY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO AFTER I SKIPPED
FRANKIE B. JEANS,
I GO TO HOUSE CASTING,
AND THEY GIVE ME
THIS LITTLE SHEET,
AND I HAVE TO MEMORIZE
THIS COMMERCIAL.
>> I FINALLY GET TO THE CASTING,
AND MOLLY'S AHEAD OF ME.
>> MOLLY.
>> AND I WAIT. I WAIT IT OUT.
AND I'M LIKE, I STILL
CAN MAKE ALL THE OTHER ONES.
I'M--I'M OKAY.
>> AND ACTION.
>> IT CAN BE HARD TO MAKE
HEALTHY EATING CHOICES
FOR EVERY MEAL, EVERY DAY,
IN EVERY WAY.
WANNA KNOW MY SECRET?
>> UM, WE CAN TRY
MAKE IT A LITTLE FRIENDLIER.
OKAY?
>> WANNA KNOW MY SECRET?
>> MOLLY NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO BE FRIENDLIER ON CAMERA.
SHE COULD KIND OF
LET LOOSE A LITTLE MORE
IN THE AUDITION.
AND ACTION.
>> ...EVERY MEAL, EVERY DAY,
IN EVERY WAY.
WANNA KNOW MY SECRET?
>> GREAT.
I WOULD BOOK ALEXANDRIA.
SHE'S VERY FRIENDLY
AND SHE SEEMED
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE.
(bell dings)
>> WELL, THIS IS THE 101.
SO WE NEED TO GO--
BE GOING THAT WAY. NORTH.
NO, WE NEED TO GO THIS WAY.
I HAVE NEVER PICKED UP A MAP
BEFORE IN MY LIFE,
BECAUSE I LIVE IN BELTON, TEXAS.
THERE'S A WALMART,
THERE'S A BUSH'S CHICKEN,
BUT NOTHING BIG.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T NEED A MAP.
GOD, THIS SUCKS.
>> ARE WE GOING STRAIGHT
OR ARE WE GOING LEFT?
>> WE'RE GOING STRAIGHT.
>> THAT WAY?
>> I MEAN LEFT. LEFT. LEFT.
RIGHT HERE.
(tires screech)
>> I HAVE NO SENSE OF DIRECTION.
I CAN'T READ A MAP
FOR THE LIFE OF ME.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO CLUE
WHERE IN THE HELL I'M GOING.
UGH!
>> SO THE SECOND GO-SEE
I WENT TO WAS THE COUTURE ONE.
ODAY SHAKAR IS THE DESIGNER,
AND THAT ONE, I THOUGHT,
WENT REALLY WELL.
>> KASIA WAS GREAT.
I COULD SEE THE CLIENTS
REALLY LIKING HER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I DID END UP MAKING IT
TO A SECOND GO-SEE.
AND I THOUGHT I WAS FRIENDLY
AND PROFESSIONAL
'CAUSE I WAS JUST REALLY
STRIVING FOR PROFESSIONAL TODAY.
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE BRITTANI.
I THINK SHE HAD A GOOD WALK.
>> IT WAS REALLY NICE
MEETING YOU.
>> IT WAS A PLEASURE
TO MEET YOU.
>> SOMEHOW, LUCKILY,
THANK THE LORD, HALLELUJAH,
I FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET
TO THE GIRL NEXT DOOR GO-SEE.
AND IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO KICK BUTT,
BECAUSE I REALLY WANT
TO GO TO MOROCCO.
>> ACTION.
>> IT CAN BE HARD
TO MAKE HEALTHY CHOICES
FOR EVERY MEAL AND--OH, SORRY.
(beep)
>> IT CAN VERY HARD
TO MAKE HEALTHY EATING CHOICES.
YOU WANT TO KNOW MY SECRET?
>> CAN YOU DO
NOT A SOUTHERN ACCENT?
>> YOU WANNA KNOW MY SECRET?
>> JACLYN HAS AN ACCENT
THAT COULD BE A PROBLEM
WHEN WE HAVE LOTS OF LINES
THAT WE NEED, UH,
MODELS AND ACTRESSES TO RECITE.
(bell dings)
>> I KINDA START
GETTING THE HANG OF THE MAP,
SO I GET TO THE NEXT PLACE,
WHICH IS THE ATHLETIC ONE.
>> GO.
DID YOU BRING ANY ATHLETIC WEAR
WITH YOU? LIKE...
>> UM, I DID NOT.
I HAVE...
>> BUT YOU'RE COMING
TO A SPORTS CASTING.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE
THAT I HAD TO WEAR
ATHLETIC CLOTHES. (groans)
BUT I HAVE NUDE BOOTY SHORTS,
AND I ROLL MY TANK TOP UP
SO IT LOOKS KINDA LIKE
A SPORTS BRA.
THEN I JUST WALK IN.
I'M BAREFOOT.
>> ONE, TWO, THREE.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> WOW!
I WISH MOLLY HAD COME PREPARED
FOR THE CASTING.
BUT I GAVE HER A SHOT,
AND SHE EXCEEDED
MY EXPECTATIONS.
THANK YOU.
>> AWESOME. THANK YOU.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THIS IS NOT COOL.
YES!
HA HA!
THANK YOU, MOLLY.
THANK GOD MOLLY RAN OUT,
'CAUSE I WAS RUNNING AROUND
THE STREETS LOST.
>> DID YOU BRING ANYTHING
WITH YOU THAT WOULD BE ATHLETIC?
>> I HAVE A SWIMSUIT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THIS IS SO CONFUSING.
(train horn honks)
>> (groans)
I WAS REALLY FLUSTERED
AND GETTING ANXIOUS
WHILE I WAS IN THE CAR
BECAUSE I'M JUST WORRIED
THAT ME GETTING LOST
AND HAVING A STRUGGLE
NAVIGATING THROUGH L.A.
IS GOING TO BE MY DOWNFALL.
AND SO I'M REALLY FEELING
RIGHT NOW
THAT I'M GONNA PLAY IT SAFE
AND JUST GO TO LANA MARKS.
♪♪♪♪♪
(bell dings)
>> IF I GO TO ONE MORE GO-SEE,
I WOULD GET LOST,
AND THEN I WOULD BE LATE
AND I WOULD BE DISQUALIFIED,
SO I THOUGHT IT WAS BETTER
TO BE SAFE THAN SORRY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I HAVE TO CHANGE
INTO A SWIMSUIT RIGHT NOW.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> I RUN OUTSIDE,
TOOK MY PANTS DOWN.
I WAS WEARING A THONG,
SO IT'S NOT LIKE
I WAS EMBARRASSING MYSELF.
EXCUSE ME!
RAN BACK INTO THE CASTING,
AND WAS LIKE, YEP.
>> (growls)
>> I THINK YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
HAVE YOU BACK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT WAS VERY NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH,
ALEXANDRIA.
IT WAS MY PLEASURE.
>> YES!
>> WHEN I WALK INTO LANA MARKS,
I SEE JACLYN AND BRITTANI
WAITING, AND BY THEIR
BODY POSTURE, I CAN TELL THEY'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR A WHILE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> ♪ I MADE IT ♪
HEY.
>> 'CAUSE I CAN STILL
MAYBE MAKE THE OTHER ONE
IF NO ONE'S THERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M REALLY DECIDING
ON IF I CAN MAKE IT
TO THE COUTURE BOMBSHELL
ON WILSHIRE,
WHICH I REALLY WANTED TO MAKE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I SAY NO.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MOLLY.
>> WE ALL MADE IT.
>> SO I GET TO LANA MARKS,
AND FOUR OF THE GIRLS
ARE ALREADY THERE.
ALEXANDRIA ISN'T THERE YET,
AND I'M LIKE,
I HOPE SHE DOESN'T MAKE IT.
WHAT TIME IS IT?
>> IT'S RIGHT THERE, BOO.
>> HOW IS ALEXANDRIA
THE LAST ONE?
SHE MUST'VE TRIED
TO GO TO ALL OF THEM.
MAYBE SHE'S GONNA BE LATE.
OHH!
>> THE WINNER.
>> HEY.
>> SHE DOES MAKE IT ON TIME,
LIKE A CHAMP.
JUST ON TIME.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU ALL MADE IT BACK IN TIME.
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL WONDERING
HOW WELL YOU DID TODAY,
BECAUSE THE THREE WINNERS
OF TODAY'S CHALLENGE
WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THE ULTIMATE GO-SEE
HERE AT LANA MARKS' SALON.
THE THREE GIRLS
THAT DID THE BEST
AMONGST TODAY'S DESIGNERS
WERE...
MOLLY, ALEXANDRIA...
>> YAY!
>> AND KASIA.
YOU THREE MADE IT
TO THE MOST GO-SEES
AND GOT THE BEST FEEDBACK.
HANNAH, THE DESIGNERS SAID
YOUR RUNWAY WALK
NEEDS A LOT OF WORK.
AND BRITTANI AND JACLYN
ONLY MADE IT TO TWO GO-SEES,
WHICH JUST DOESN'T CUT IT.
>> (inhales sharply)
I JUST FEEL REALLY DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF.
AND I FEEL LIKE
I JUST SIGNED MY TICKET HOME.
>> YOU GUYS CAN GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HELLO, GIRLS.
>> HI.
>> ONE OF YOU
WHO IMPRESSES ME MOST TODAY
IS GOING TO STAR
IN MY NEXT GLOBAL CAMPAIGN,
FEATURED IN OVER 100 COUNTRIES.
>> I'M SO HAPPY TO BE
IN THE TOP THREE
FOR THE GO-SEE CHALLENGE.
THE WINNER GETS TO BE
IN HER CAMPAIGN.
IT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL.
>> YOU WILL ALSO RECEIVE
A GIFT BAG
FROM SOME OF TODAY'S DESIGNERS
AS WELL AS AN EXACT REPLICA
OF THE CLEOPATRA CLUTCH
WORN BY ANGELINA JOLIE
AT LAST YEAR'S OSCARS
AT A VALUE OF $2,000.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> (laughs)
>> (bleep) LOVE ANGELINA JOLIE.
I WANT THIS CLUTCH.
I WANNA WIN THIS.
I HAVEN'T WON
A (bleep) CHALLENGE YET.
>> WHO OF THE THREE OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO START?
>> I WOULD.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M STANDING UP.
>> GIVE ME
YOUR MOST FABULOUS POSE.
(camera shutter click)
>> FABULOUS.
IF YOU WIN THIS CAMPAIGN,
WHAT IS IT GONNA MEAN TO YOU?
(chuckles)
>> WHAT WOULD IT NOT MEAN TO ME?
>> AND ALEXANDRIA GOES,
"WHAT DOESN'T IT MEAN TO ME?"
IT'S LIKE, IF YOU CAN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING GOOD TO SAY,
YOU (bleep).
>> I AM CAPABLE
OF ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
BECAUSE I'M UP
FOR ANY CHALLENGE.
>> "AND NA, NA, NA, NA."
SHUT UP.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH. TERRIFIC.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> AND LET'S SEE
WHAT YOU CAN DO.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> ...WHY YOU'D LIKE
TO WIN THIS CAMPAIGN.
>> UM, I JUST THINK
IT WOULD BE AMAZING.
>> NICE. NICE.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> SO TELL ME WHY YOU WANT
TO BE PART OF THIS CAMPAIGN.
>> I'VE WORKED HARD TO, LIKE,
FEEL SO GOOD ABOUT MYSELF,
AND I LOVE MY BODY.
AND IT'S JUST A MATTER OF, LIKE,
SHOWING OTHER PEOPLE
THAT IT'S OKAY TO BE DIFFERENT.
>> KASIA, PLEASURE TO MEET YOU.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> SO I'M TERRIBLY SORRY
THAT I ONLY HAVE TO PICK ONE,
AND IT'S ALEXANDRIA.
>> I REALLY CAN'T EXPLAIN
HOW THANKFUL I AM.
I'M JUST SO OVERWHELMED
BY WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> IT'S A PLEASURE.
I CHOSE ALEXANDRIA
BECAUSE SHE'S A NATURAL,
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
AND SHE WAS MAGNIFICENT.
WHEN I SAW MOLLY POSE,
IT WAS MAGNIFICENT,
BUT WHEN I SAW THE GIRL
SITTING DOWN ON THE SOFA,
MOLLY WASN'T QUITE
THE POISED MODEL
THAT I WAS LOOKING FOR.
THANK YOU.
BYE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO WHAT ALL DID YOU WIN?
>> OH, WOW, ALEXANDRIA.
>> IT'S, LIKE, A CLEOPATRA BAG.
>> WOW.
>> COOL.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> YEAH.
>> I WANNA WIN
THE (bleep) CHALLENGE ALREADY.
I'M REALLY GETTING ANGRY.
I DO NOT LIKE LOSING.
I'M PISSED OFF!
I BETTER BE GOING TO MOROCCO
OR I SWEAR TO GOD,
I WILL PUNCH A HOLE
IN SOMETHING.
>> (gasps)
>> TODAY I WAS JEALOUS
BECAUSE ALEXANDRIA WON,
AND SHE HAD
GIFTS AND GIFTS GALORE,
AND I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING
TO BE GOING HOME NEXT,
BECAUSE I DID POORLY TODAY.
SO I'M JUST KINDA
PREPARING MYSELF FOR THE WORST.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> OH!
>> TYRA MAIL.
"A MODELING CAREER IS
A TERRIBLE THING TO WASTE."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO WE ARRIVE
AT THE OLINDA LANDFILL.
IT'S A BIG OLD PLACE
WHERE EVERYONE DUMPS
ALL THEIR TRASH.
IT'S NASTY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
(seagulls crying)
>> HELLO. GOOD MORNING.
IT SMELLS
JUST A LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
YEAH, I MEAN, YOU BETTER GET
USED TO IT, 'CAUSE GUESS WHAT.
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE
ALL DAY LONG.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LADIES.
AND TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
SHOOTING YOU IN
AN ECO-FRIENDLY FASHION SHOOT.
>> YOU ARE GONNA BE WEARING
MAGNIFICENT, ECO-FRIENDLY
COUTURE CREATIONS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU...
>> AAH!
>> BY MICHAEL CINCO,
WHO IS INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED
FOR HIS
HAUTE COUTURE EVENING GOWNS.
>> HI, NIGEL.
>> HI.
>> HEY, MICHAEL.
>> HI, JAY.
SO I SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
COUTURE DRESSES FOR YOU GIRLS
USING RECYCLED MATERIALS
LIKE BROKEN MIRRORS
AND MAKE THEM LOOK LIKE
EXPENSIVE GEMSTONES.
>> I FEEL GREAT ABOUT
THE ECO-FRIENDLY SHOOT.
AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE PEOPLE
WILL THINK TWICE
BEFORE THROWING OUT
SO MUCH GARBAGE.
>> AS ALWAYS,
WE ARE WORKING OUT
OF THE QUIXOTE VERDE MOTOR HOME,
WHICH IS THE GREENEST IN L.A.
IT RUNS ENTIRELY ON BIODIESEL
AND IS MADE
FROM RECYCLED MATERIALS.
LET'S GO TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND LET'S MAKE SOME MAGIC TODAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE'RE JUST PUTTING YOU--
AN ELEMENT OF COLOR
INTO YOUR FACE.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
A GREAT JUXTAPOSITION.
>> LOOK UP FOR ME.
>> THE PRESSURE IS
DEFINITELY ON TODAY.
LAST WEEK AT PANEL,
NIGEL KIND OF CALLED ME OUT.
>> TO BE THAT OUTSPOKEN
AT A PHOTO SHOOT WAS
EXTREMELY UNPROFESSIONAL.
>> AND I HOPE I CAN
TURN THIS ALL AROUND
AND PROVE MYSELF
TO THE REST OF THE JUDGES
THAT DID WANT ME HERE,
LIKE, MAKE THEM PROUD
AND SHOW THEM, LISTEN,
YOU DID MAKE THE RIGHT CHOICE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'VE GOT YOU SCOOPED UP.
>> SCOOPED UP?
>> SCOOPED UP IN THE SCOOP.
>> OH, YAY!
>> EYES UP.
BEAUTIFUL THERE.
YOUR FACE FORWARD.
FACE FORWARD.
KASIA'S BIGGEST ISSUE IS
HER RANGE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS.
FINESSE IT, WORK IT,
AND THAT'S WHERE THE MAGIC
WILL COME.
YOU LOOK WICKED.
>> I'M NOT NO PRINCESS ANYMORE.
I COMPLETELY BOMBED GO-SEES,
SO EVERYTHING IS RIDING
ON THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
IF I DON'T DO GOOD,
I'M NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO MOROCCO WITH THE OTHER GIRLS,
AND SO I'VE REALLY
GOT TO OUTSHINE THEM.
>> SORRY. MY LEGS--OOH! SORRY.
>> OKAY. NOW GO... UGH!
>> OH, NO!
IT LANDED ON YOU INSTEAD OF ME.
>> IT POOPED ON ME
INSTEAD OF HER.
>> ALL THE SEAGULLS.
>> WELL, I SAVED THE DRESS,
I GUESS. UGH!
(camera shutter clicking)
>> RELAX THE FACE.
CHIN UP FOR ME.
AND, JACLYN, RELAX THE MOUTH.
AH.
THE AREA THAT JACLYN
REALLY NEEDS TO WORK ON IS
CONTROLLING HER FACE.
BUT THAT BEING SAID,
HER PERSONALITY IS
VERY ENDEARING.
>> GOOD.
>> WIDER EYES. WIDER EYES.
BIGGER EYES. LOOK HIGHER.
LOOK ABOVE ME.
>> USE YOUR ARMS.
SHOW THE GOWN.
YOU HAVE TO WORK THE GARMENT.
>> HOLD THAT.
>> WHEN YOU DON'T
SECOND-GUESS YOURSELF,
IT'S SO GREAT,
BUT THEN WHEN YOU'RE
SECOND-GUESSING YOURSELF,
I CAN TELL,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GOING, UH...
>> LET'S GO LIKE THAT.
BEAUTIFUL,
>> OH, THAT'S BEAUTIFUL,
DIRECT ON.
>> MR. JAY TOLD ME
TO STOP SECOND-GUESSING MYSELF,
AND THAT'S WHEN I REALLY
STARTED FEELING THESE MOMENTS,
AND I THINK
I GOT AN AMAZING SHOT.
>> HELLO, BRITTANI.
>> HELLO, NIGEL.
>> SO LISTEN,
I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU,
OBVIOUSLY SINCE THE LAST TIME
I SAW YOU WAS AT JUDGING.
IT WAS QUITE TRAUMATIC
FOR EVERYBODY, I THINK.
BUT LISTEN, I WANT YOU
TO REALIZE THAT I,
AS WELL AS THE OTHER JUDGES,
HAVE FAITH IN YOU.
OTHERWISE,
YOU WOULD NOT BE HERE.
>> I WOULD NOT BE HERE.
YEAH, I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> YOU KNOW? AND SO--
>> AND I KNOW THAT I HAVE
A LOT TO PROVE TODAY.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE A LOT TO--
>> KIND OF STEP UP TO THE PLATE.
I TALKED TO NIGEL
BEFORE THE SHOOT,
AND I'M REALLY THANKFUL
FOR THAT, BECAUSE NOW I'M JUST
KIND OF TRYING TO BE OPTIMISTIC.
BUT IF I DON'T MEET EXPECTATIONS
AND PROVE THE JUDGES RIGHT
FOR KEEPING ME,
I'M GOING HOME.
>> HELLO, YOU.
>> DOESN'T SHE LOOK FANTASTIC?
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> WE'RE WALKING ON SET,
AND LITERALLY SIX PEOPLE
HAVE TO CARRY MY DRESS.
IT'S AMAZING.
I FELT LIKE A QUEEN
ON TOP OF A BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE ON HERE.
THE GOWN'S GONNA DRAPE OFF.
BUT THE IDEA
IS THAT YOU'RE GIANT.
YOU'RE REALLY TALL.
GORG!
THROW THE HEAD BACK. DRAMA!
>> I LOVE THIS BROKEN-DOWN FEEL.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
I WAS LOOKING FOR.
IT WAS SO CLEAR
ALEXANDRIA WAS REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT WE WERE DOING.
HER HANDS WOULD
JUST KIND OF FALL,
AND THEY WERE SO GRACEFUL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> MM, THANK YOU.
>> YOU WORKED IT OUT. MWAH.
>> OH. MWAH.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> GORGEOUS!
EYES TO ME. FACE TO ME.
>> IT SMELLS HORRIBLE.
THERE ARE BIRDS EVERYWHERE.
AND NO ONE WANTS TO STAND
IN A PILE OF TRASH.
SO THIS IS NASTY,
MY WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> GORGEOUS THERE.
>> UGH!
AGAIN?
>> THAT IS GROSS.
THIS IS UNSANITARY.
>> BACK TO SECOND.
CHECK OUR LIGHT.
>> DOES ANYBODY HAVE A BB GUN?
SHOTGUN?
>> MOLLY--SHE'S A GREAT MODEL
WHEN SHE'S MODELING.
THE PROBLEM WITH MOLLY IS,
IS THAT WHEN YOU BRING
THE CAMERA DOWN, SOMETIMES
YOU'RE GONNA GET A GIRL
THAT'S GONNA BE COMPLAINING,
GONNA BE MISERABLE,
GONNA BE ANGRY ABOUT IT.
THERE'S NO NEED TO GO THERE.
>> I HATE YOU, BIRDS.
(seagull cries)
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicking)
>> A LITTLE TALLER,
A LITTLE LONGER.
THROW YOUR ARMS IN THE AIR.
HIGH! BEAUTIFUL.
BOTH! BOTH ARMS!
YOU KNOW WHAT MIGHT
BE REALLY COOL?
>> IF I SIT DOWN?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NOW THIS IS A GIRL
WHO WANTS A SHOT.
SHE IS DOWN IN THE GARBAGE.
THAT LOOKS REALLY HOT.
>> SO IT'S, LIKE,
DO-OR-DIE, BRITTANI.
YOU KIND OF DIDN'T DO WELL
AT PANEL,
AND THEN YOU SUCKED
AT THE GO-SEES,
AND IF YOU DON'T GET
A GOOD PICTURE, AND YOU'RE JUST
KINDA LAGGING BEHIND,
YOU'RE GOING HOME.
>> THAT'S A WRAP
ON THE BIRD POOP, EVERYONE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OKAY. GO.
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 5 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!"
>> I REALLY HOPE
I HAVE A GREAT PICTURE
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT
TO BE ELIMINATED.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE OF ME
THAT THE JUDGES
HAVE NOT SEEN YET.
I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WANT TO PROVE TO THEM
THAT I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
>> DO YOU THINK, THOUGH,
BECAUSE WE WON YESTERDAY...
>> THAT WE'RE--THAT WE'RE SET?
>> WE'RE SAFE?
>> I THINK SO.
>> 'CAUSE WASN'T--
TYRA SAID, LIKE--
>> UNLESS WE GET, LIKE,
A JUST DISGUSTING PICTURE...
>> HORRIBLE PHOTO.
>> WHICH IS DOUBTFUL.
I DID WELL ON THE GO-SEE
AND I KILLED IT
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
I MEAN, UNLESS THEY'VE
LITERALLY GONE MENTAL,
LIKE, I'M GOING TO MOROCCO.
THERE'S NO WAY
THAT I'M GETTING SENT HOME.
IF I DO, I WILL, MM...
(bleep) FREAK OUT.
(chuckles)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> CAN'T YOU PUT IT INSIDE?
>> IT JUST LOOKS SO...
>> OH, LOOK, LOOK. (laughs)
>> (laughs)
>> ALL THESE...
>> OH, MY--WOW!
OH, YOU LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE GOING
TO SOME BAD RIDING SCHOOL.
>> WHAT?
♪♪♪♪♪
AND THEN THERE WERE SIX.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS, ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
A COVER OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
AND A SPREAD,
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN,
AND YOU'LL BE FEATURED
ON vogue.it, THEIR WEB SITE.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
MR. ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY,
THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL PERSON
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND LANA MARKS.
LANA MARKS IS THE C.E.O.
OF LANA MARKS,
AND SHE'S KNOWN FOR MAKING
SOME OF THE WORLD'S
MOST EXPENSIVE HANDBAGS.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
WE ARE GOING TO CALL DOWN
ALEXANDRIA FIRST.
INTERESTING THAT YOUR SHIRT
SAYS "NUMBER ONE."
SO THE GIRLS WENT ON GO-SEES
THIS WEEK.
YOU MADE HOW MANY GO-SEES
OUT OF FIVE?
>> FOUR.
>> AND YOU WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> YES.
>> WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND YOU WON
LANA MARKS' AD CAMPAIGN.
>> YES, I DID.
>> DO YOU WANNA KNOW
HOW MANY YOU BOOKED?
>> HOW MANY?
>> EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
>> REALLY?
>> YOUR OVERALL CRITIQUE WAS
THAT YOU WERE PREPARED,
OUTGOING, AND FRIENDLY.
TO ME, YOU'RE THAT EXAMPLE
OF HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO GO IN THERE
AND TO WOW AND TO CONNECT.
SO YOU ALSO DID A PHOTO SHOOT.
ARE YOU READY TO SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> I'M VERY EXCITED. YES.
>> YOU WERE EXTRAORDINARY,
ALEXANDRIA.
YOUR WORKED WITH IT.
YOU WERE ON A LADDER.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT AT HER,
SHE'S LITERALLY STANDING
ABOUT NINE OR TEN FEET TALL.
>> THIS IS TRUE HIGH FASHION.
THIS PICTURE LOOKS LIKE A PAGE
THAT FRANCA SOZZANI WOULD HAVE
AS A DOUBLE PAGE SPREAD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE FACE AND THE EXPRESSION
IS WHAT SAYS IT ALL.
>> YOU--YOU ARE TOTALLY THE STAR
OF THE PICTURE.
>> YEAH.
>> THE BIRDS, THE POOP,
THE EAU DE FUNK
DID NOT TAKE OVER,
NOR DID THE DRESS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> UP NEXT--JACLYN.
>> HELLO.
>> HOW CUTE TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO, JACLYN, HOW MANY GO-SEES
DID YOU GET TO?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY,
I ONLY MADE IT TO TWO.
IT WAS HARD FOR ME,
D-DEALING WITH THE MAP,
SO, UM, I HAD A LOT
OF DIFFICULTY GETTING AROUND.
>> JUMP OUT OF THE CAR
THE NEXT TIME AND JUST RUN.
>> OH, YES.
>> JACLYN, YOU CANNOT MISS
A GO-SEE.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE
FOR MISSING THAT.
I'M SORRY.
THIS IS THE CHANCE
OF A LIFETIME.
>> SO OUT OF THE TWO GO-SEES,
YOU BOOKED BOTH.
YOU WOWED THEM
WITH YOUR PERSONALITY
AND AMAZING BODY.
HOW DID YOU FEEL
ABOUT YOUR PHOTO SHOOT?
>> I FEEL REAL GOOD
ABOUT MY PHOTO SHOOT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU HAVE TO LEARN IS MODELING
YOUR FACE, 'CAUSE YOU GAVE ME
LOTS OF POSES WITH YOUR BODY,
BUT CLENCHING YOUR JAW,
OPENING YOUR MOUTH
WORKS YOUR FACE.
AND YOU HAVE A SOFT JAWLINE,
SO YOU REALLY WANNA WORK THAT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
>> YES. OKAY.
>> I THINK YOUR HAND,
YOUR LEFT ARM,
COULD BE A LITTLE BIT
CONSIDERED GAUCHE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> UP NEXT IS MOLLY.
YOU WENT TO GO-SEES.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND YOU MADE IT
TO FOUR OUT OF FIVE
AND YOU BOOKED TWO JOBS.
THE GENERAL NOTE WAS
ALL THE GO-SEES
LOVED YOUR PORTFOLIO
AND YOUR LOOK,
BUT YOU COME ACROSS COLD
AND NOT PRESENT.
THEY REALLY NOTICED
YOUR OFF MOMENTS
WHEN YOU THOUGHT
YOU WEREN'T BEING JUDGED.
INTERESTING.
>> HMM.
>> ONE THING IN FASHION IS
YOU'RE ALWAYS BEING WATCHED.
ALWAYS.
>> IT'S MY MAIN NOTE FOR YOU.
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT,
EVERY TIME THE CAMERA
WOULD GO DOWN,
YOU WOULD HAVE THIS OFF MOMENT.
IT WOULD THROW ME.
A LITTLE BIRDIE TOLD ME
THAT HAD YOU SMILED
AND HAD MORE OF A CONSISTENT
POSITIVE ATTITUDE,
THAT YOU WOULD'VE BEEN
STARRING IN HER AD.
>> MM.
>> 100% CORRECT.
>> AND SO IT'S ABOUT FAKING IT
WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE CRAP,
JUST GOING,
"HI, TYRA." (giggles)
AND AS SOON AS, YOU KNOW,
I TURN MY BACK,
"OH, GOD, I'M SO TIRED."
AND I TURN BACK AROUND. "WHOO!"
THE CLIENT HAS THE CONTROL
OF YOUR DESTINY.
SO YOU NEED TO WORK THAT CLIENT.
ARE WE READY
FOR OUR BEST SHOT?
>> YES.
>> GORG.
>> THIS IS AN AMAZING
EDITORIAL PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK THAT IT'S VERY DRAMATIC
AND I THINK YOU LOOK WONDERFUL.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS
LISTEN TO
THESE TEACHABLE MOMENTS HERE
WHICH ARE REALLY KEY
AND CRUCIAL.
BECAUSE HERE YOU ARE
LOOKING EXTRAORDINARY,
BUT THEN BEHIND THE SCENES,
THERE IS A-A LACK OF DISCIPLINE
AND A LACK OF FOCUS.
LANA JUST SAID
YOU WERE NUMBER ONE,
AND YOU WERE BUMPED
BECAUSE YOU WERE DEJECTED
IN HER STORE.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE HER BAGS,
YOU GOTTA SAY, "OH,
I LOVE THE BRASS ON THIS BAG.
IT'S FABULOUS.
CAN I HAVE THIS BAG?"
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> (chuckles)
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS KASIA.
SO, KASIA, HOW MANY GO-SEES
DID YOU MAKE IT TO?
>> FOUR.
>> YOU BOOKED TWO.
YOU ENGAGED EACH OF THE CASTINGS
TO ENSURE
THAT THEY REMEMBERED YOU,
BUT AT TIMES,
YOU ALSO CAME ACROSS
REHEARSED AND FORCED.
>> (mouths word)
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THIS SHOT IS AMAZING.
YOU HAVE AN EXPRESSION
ON YOUR FACE
THAT'S ALMOST MYSTICAL.
IT JUST SAYS EVERYTHING.
IT GOES SO PERFECTLY
WITH THE SHOT.
THIS IS A LOVELY SHOT,
GORGEOUS SHOT,
BUT I FELT LIKE
YOU JUST WEREN'T MOVING.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS KIND OF STUCK.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THE BEST PARTS
AND HOW TO WORK YOUR BODY.
LIKE, I KNOW THAT
I DON'T HAVE CALVES.
LIKE, ACTUALLY,
I STUFFED BY BOOTS...
>> SHOES.
>> WITH LEG WARMERS
TO MAKE THEM BIGGER.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
>> BUT THERE'S THINGS I DO
IN PHOTOS TO GET AROUND THAT.
AND YOU HAVE TO LEARN
THE TRICKS FOR YOUR BODY.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> UP NEXT IS HANNAH.
HOW MANY GO-SEES DID YOU GET TO?
>> THREE.
>> HANNAH, YOU BOOKED TWO JOBS.
>> THEY SAID YOU CAME OFF
"YOUNG, FRESH, AND GLOWING,.
HOWEVER, YOU ALSO CAME ACROSS
GREEN AND INEXPERIENCED
AND YOU STRUGGLED
WITH YOUR RUNWAY WALK."
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOUR POSTURE WITH THIS SHOT
IS REMARKABLE.
THE WAY YOU'VE TURNED YOUR BODY,
YOU'RE SHOWING OFF THE GOWN.
>> YOU ARE WEARING THE DRESS.
THE DRESS IS NOT WEARING YOU.
>> YOU DID SO WELL,
AND I HEARD THAT YOU WERE
KINDA DOUBTING YOURSELF.
YOU HAVE TO CATCH UP
TO WHERE YOUR ABILITIES ARE.
RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE THE GIRL
WHO STILL THINKS
SHE'S THE LITTLE GIRL
THAT WANTS TO BE A MODEL
AND HAS ALL--
OTHER PERSONAL ISSUES
AND DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
SHE CAN ACCOMPLISH
CERTAIN THINGS, BUT THAT'S NOT
WHERE YOUR ABILITY IS.
SO YOU NEED TO CATCH UP
TO YOURSELF.
ALL RIGHT? THANKS.
>> (whispers) THANKS.
>> UP NEXT--BRITTANI.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING
AFTER ALL OF THE DRAMA
FROM LAST WEEK?
>> I WAS HOPING I WOULD GET
TO THIS, 'CAUSE I REALLY WANTED
TO APOLOGIZE.
I JUST--I'M REALLY SORRY,
AND ALL WEEK,
I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, I ACCEPT YOUR APOLOGY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE MORE IMPORTANT APOLOGY
SHOULD GO
TO SOMEBODY BEHIND YOU.
>> WE ALL TALKED ABOUT IT,
AND I APOLOGIZED TO ALEXANDRIA,
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IT
SHOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
WHERE IT DID.
>> SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOU COMING AROUND
AND NOT MAKING ME FEEL LIKE
THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
>> THAT WAS
THE LAST THING I WANTED.
>> SO HOW MANY GO-SEES
DID YOU GET TO?
>> I ONLY GOT TO TWO.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR IT.
I'M TOTALLY TAKING THE BLAME,
'CAUSE I GOT ON THE FREEWAY,
AND I THINK THAT WAS
MY BIGGEST MISTAKE.
>> OUT OF THE TWO
THAT YOU GOT TO, YOU BOOKED TWO.
AND YOUR WALK
IMPRESSED THEM ALL.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> FIRST, YOUR DRESS IS
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
AND THIS IS SO HIGH FASHION.
IT'S SO FRANCA SOZZANI.
IT IS SO EDITORIAL.
>> YOU REALLY, REALLY WORKED IT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO FOCUS
ON NOT TRYING SO HARD
THAT YOU GET STIFF,
'CAUSE THEN YOUR NECK MUSCLES
GO, YOU KNOW, LIKE,
"OOH, SHE WANTS THIS.
SHE'S TRYIN'. SHE'S TRYIN'.
SHE WANTS IT SO BAD."
SO IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
GETTING THAT INTENSITY
AND THEN LETTING IT GO.
GETTING THE INTENSITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WE WILL TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION
YOUR PHOTOS THIS WEEK,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
YOUR GO-SEES.
AND WHEN YOU COME BACK.
I WILL ANNOUNCE THE FIVE OF YOU
THAT ARE GOING
TO MARRAKECH, MOROCCO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> GO-SEES.
GUNK.
>> GUNK.
>> TIME TO GELIBERATE.
>> AND ELIMINATE.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> ALEXANDRIA WENT
TO FOUR OUT OF FIVE CASTINGS,
AND THE FOUR CASTINGS
SHE WENT TO, SHE BOOKED.
>> SHE BOOKED.
>> THAT'S ALMOST UNHEARD OF.
>> WHEN I LOOKED
AT THE HEADSHOTS,
SHE WAS NOT MY FIRST CHOICE,
BUT WHEN I SAW HER IN REAL LIFE,
SHE HAD WHAT I THOUGHT IT TOOK,
BECAUSE I WANT HER TO BE
THE MODEL OFF CAMERA
AS WELL AS ON CAMERA.
>> JACLYN.
>> THIS IS NOT
MY FAVORITE PICTURE OF JACLYN.
I THINK HER ARM
LOOKS VERY AWKWARD,
AND NO EXCUSE,
AS YOU SAID, LANA,
TO MISS THE GO-SEES.
>> KASIA.
KASIA'S HIT OR MISS.
SHE'S EITHER LIKE, POW!
>> YEAH.
>> THERE IT SOARS OUT THE PARK.
(imitates bugle call)
OR... (grunts) OUT.
HANNAH.
>> THIS IS A HIGH FASHION POSE,
AND IT WORKED.
>> I FELT, TYRA,
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING TO HER,
I FELT SHE WAS GONNA
BREAK OUT INTO TEARS
EVERY THREE SECONDS.
AND SHE NEEDS TO GET PAST THAT
AND JUST BE THIS BEAUTIFUL MODEL
THAT SHE CAN BE.
>> YEAH, THERE'S A FRAGILITY
INSIDE OF HER THAT I'M NOT SURE
IS STRONG ENOUGH
FOR THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
BRITTANI.
>> YOU KNOW,
SHE'S GOT A GREAT FACE,
SHE'S GOT GREAT EYES,
BUT HER BODY SHE DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH CONTROL OVER.
>> I JUST THINK THAT SHE'S DONE
AN INCREDIBLE JOB HERE.
I SEE HER IN AN INCREDIBLE
COSMETICS CAMPAIGN.
>> I AGREE WITH LANA.
SHE HAS AN AMAZING POTENTIAL.
>> BUT SHE ONLY MADE IT
TO TWO GO-SEES.
MOLLY.
>> SOME OF HER PHOTOGRAPHS ARE
SOME OF THE STRONGEST PICTURES
OF THE BUNCH,
BUT WHEN I SEE HER IN PERSON,
I THINK THAT
SHE SORT OF STANDS THERE,
SHE'S LOOKS SLIGHTLY AWKWARD,
SHE'S SLIGHTLY OFFISH.
A CLIENT MIGHT THINK
SHE DOESN'T CARE.
>> YEAH.
>> NOW THE QUESTION IS,
WILL SHE BOOK THE JOB?
>> I THINK SHE'S
A LITTLE INSECURE...
>> MM.
>> AND I THINK IT'S TRANSLATING
AS NOT CARING.
>> ARE WE READY
TO SEND HER TO FRANCA SOZZANI?
>> I DON'T KNOW. ARE WE?
WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
>> YES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SIX BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FIVE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE FIVE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE FIVE LOVELY LADIES
THAT ARE GOING
TO MARRAKECH, MOROCCO.
SO NUMBER ONE GIRL THIS WEEK
IS...
ALEXANDRIA.
INTERESTING YOU DECIDED
TO WEAR THAT SHIRT THIS WEEK.
>> VERY, VERY, VERY INTERESTING.
>> VERY INTERESTING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> HANNAH.
>> I HAVE TO WORK ON IT.
>> MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE WALK
IS THE CONFIDENCE.
>> FROM HERE ON OUT,
IT'S CONFIDENCE ALL THE WAY.
>> OKAY. LET'S TRY IT AGAIN.
(raises voice) FROM HERE
ON OUT...
>> (raises voice) FROM HERE
ON OUT,
IT'S CONFIDENCE ALL THE WAY.
>> THERE YOU GO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL...
♪ KASIA'S GOING TO MOROCCO ♪
CONGRATULATIONS, KASIA.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
BRITTANI.
>> (sighs)
>> BOY, HAVE YOU COME
A LONG WAY.
BUT YOU ONLY MADE IT
TO TWO GO-SEES,
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
IF IT WEREN'T
FOR THIS AH-MAZING PHOTO,
YOU COULD'VE GONE HOME.
YOU SHOULD BE VERY PROUD
OF YOURSELF.
I THINK YOU'VE LEARNED A LOT,
AND I'M PROUD OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MOLLY AND JACLYN,
COME ON DOWN.
TWO BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AND IS GOING TO MOROCCO.
JACLYN, YOU ONLY MADE IT
TO TWO GO-SEES,
ONLY TWO.
BUT WHAT COULD POSSIBLY SAVE YOU
IS THAT YOU BOOKED 100%
OF THE ONES THAT YOU WENT TO,
AND THEY LOVED YOUR PERSONALITY.
BUT IT WAS ONLY TWO.
AND THEN WE HAVE MOLLY.
MOLLY, YOU MADE IT
TO FOUR OUT OF FIVE--
HIGHLY COMMENDABLE.
BUT ONCE YOU GOT THERE,
THE CLIENTS SAID, "YEAH,
I MIGHT PUT HER IN A PICTURE.
I MIGHT...
I MIGHT.
BUT I DON'T LIKE
THAT PERSONALITY."
WHO STAYS IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> MOLLY.
>> (whispers) IT'S OKAY.
>> (crying)
>> THIS WAS
A VERY DIFFICULT DECISION,
AND THE JUDGES FELT
THAT YOUR BODY OF WORK WAS
SO STRONG,
AND THEY SEE A GIRL
THAT HAS A LOT OF INNER TURMOIL
AND SOME STRUGGLE.
AND SO I THINK THAT
CONVINCED THE JUDGES
THAT MAYBE YOU NEED TO DO
A LITTLE SOUL SEARCHING.
REMEMBER, WHEN YOU ARE
IN FRONT OF CLIENTS,
AT WORK,
POSITIVITY WILL BOOK THE JOB.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MISS LADY.
>> YES.
>> MISS SWEETNESS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> SO ARE WE GONNA GO HOME
AND TRY TO LEARN TO READ A MAP?
>> OH, YES.
>> RIGHT?
AND IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT
WHAT THE MAP REPRESENTS.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
>> YES, I DO.
>> YEAH?
>> I DO.
>> OKAY.
>> IT DOESN'T STOP HERE.
>> OKAY. YEAH.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT IS REALLY SAD
THAT I DON'T GET TO PARTICIPATE
IN GOING ABROAD TO MOROCCO,
BUT I FEEL SO BLESSED
THAT I GOT THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
COMING INTO THIS COMPETITION,
AND I'VE GOTTEN
SO MUCH OUT OF IT,
SO THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF A CAREER FOR ME.
AND, UM, IF ANYONE'S
LOOKING OUT FOR, YOU KNOW,
A TALL BRUNETTE WITH
A-A LOUD, SQUEAKY, FUN VOICE
AND A BIG PERSONALITY,
THEN THAT'S YOUR GIRL
RIGHT HERE.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.